Tonight, a desperate race agains
This is what's left
of an apartment building
after a deadly Russian
missile strike series in eastern
Crews searching for a family
that may still be trapped
inside the rubble
that includes an eight year old
This video also showing a six mo
old boy named Eli who was rescue
given urgent medical care.
This comes as the wife of Ukrain
top spy
chief is also recovering
after a suspected poisoning by R
It is the latest in a long list
of enemies of the Russian leader
Vladimir Putin, likely poisoned.
Fred Pleitgen is OUTFRONT.
Ukraine's military
intelligence wages war in the sh
but it is hitting the Russians h
orchestrating cruise missile
attacks on Vladimir Putin's
Black Sea Fleet.
Ousting Moscow's forces from
oil and gas
drilling platforms
off the coast of occupied Crimea
in a daring amphibious assault
and attacking the Russian capita
with long distance combat drones
While maintaining deniability.
The man leading the intelligence
you are
is Kerry Global Danoff,
one of Russia's most feared enem
Other two shares courses conveyi
I appeal to Russian soldiers,
to those who got lucky enough
to survive in destroyed trenches
He recently said it will be even
You have a choice.
Die or save your life.
But now Ukraine believes the Rus
have struck back.
Kiev saying Bogdanov wife,
Marianna Buda Nova,
has been poisoned by what they s
is, quote, a heavy metal.
A Ukrainian source
telling CNN Buda Nova
tested positive
for both arsenic and mercury poi
Ukrainian officials believe
the Kremlin could be behind it.
Like the foreign minister
right here on OUTFRONT.
Definitely our intelligence chie
is the enemy of Russia, as all o
all those
who are fighting against Russia.
So it's highly likely that Russi
behind it.
The
Kremlin controlled media already
in a feeding frenzy,
rejoicing in the news
while seemingly
brushing off the allegation.
Among the prosperous with Gladys
Maybe she just broke a thermomet
during one of the parties
with her husband's colleagues.
It's not very sensational.
But Ukrainians and their Western
literally screamed from such new
and began to blame Putin.
But in a different episode,
they brought in a Russian parlia
accused of poisoning
and killing
a former Russian agent in London
to explain how it would be done.
But really,
he was
something slipped in her teeth
and she drank it.
There's no other way to poison f
and drink
other than to pour it in
and slip it in somehow.
In the past, the U.S.
and others have accused
Vladimir Putin of ordering poiso
attacks on his opponents.
And few
groups have enraged the Russian
more than Ukraine's military
intelligence led by Bogdanov.
The former head of Ukraine's
foreign intelligence says, Yeah.
I believe that this was
a personal revenge from Putin.
Personal revenge
for all the shame
that the defense intelligence
under the leadership of burden
of have inflicted on him.
Shame that supersedes
what Prigozhin has done to him.
Putin 18
using in
an air in the Kremlin
hasn't issued a direct
denial of these allegations.
But they do seem to be trying to
brush them off as well.
The Kremlin spokesman, Dmitry Pe
he came out
and he said, quote, Ukraine blam
Russia for everything
all this, of course, as Carrillo
Boudreau's wife, is battling
those effects of that poisoning
All right.
Thank you very much, Fred Pleitg